street is giving thanks with drinks
tomorrow you can join their drinks
giving and Paul McGuire is here with all
the details first question very serious
favorite holiday drink
maybe a little hot toddy you can't go
wrong with a little hot dog I'm gonna go
with champagne all right fair enough
lovely for New Year's okay now let's get
into it I hear this is uh an epic drink
fest a comfy Bar Crawl what is
Thanksgiving on Fremont Street all right
so Thanksgiving is for family drinks
giving is for friends okay uh really
tying one on for a good old-fashioned
fashion drink fest it's really meant to
be communal it's fun and it's all
anchored we have a free concert by
Grammy awarding artist of Flo Rida you
know who Flo Rida is and I can imagine
crowd is going to be wild what's what's
the energy like because I hear this is
one of the biggest nights to party the
night before Thanksgiving it's it's a
big big party night overall and it's
great it sets up it's really a communal
uh you know festive experience so we
have it anchored by a great onesie pub
crawl uh so pictures I was seeing
pictures of it right now right so you
have 750 to a thousand adults
participate in pajamas uh having a
little bit of a pub crawl we have 12
bars to participate all underneath the
Fremont canopy so it's really super
convenient and really you can go at your
leisure uh the tickets to the pub crawl
are about to start at 35 okay and they
go all the way up to 75 dollars that 75
gets you a free VIP pass uh right right
up front with Flo Rida uh gets you free
parking uh get you some swag and a
little bit of an elevated drink special
uh mix associated with that very cool
now you know last time we met met we
were at slotzilla is that still going
for the holiday
you better now what else is going on at
the Fremont Street Experience for the
holidays I know there's like a list of
things yeah I mean we just came off of
uh Stone Temple Pilots we had a free
concert this past Saturday which
culminated our downtown Rocks concert
series we just unveiled a vivavision
show with Stone Temple Pilots uh we have
another one in the works I can't tell
you right now but that's an amazing
talent associated with that make sure we
get the exclusive yes yes exclusive with
you all we have we kick off the NFR with
our hoedown uh concert free concert
featuring Scotty McCreery Laney Wilson
just won uh uh a female artist of the
year okay um so that's fantastic we have
our Christmas tree lighting on uh the uh
December 6th all right uh and then we
have New Year's Eve oh yeah uh the Time
of Your Life Festival we have bush
we've got the list right there on your
screen thank you so much Paul